hi it's benito skinner aka benny drama
and today i've got something in store
for drew that i think she's gonna love
because what's better than one drew
two dribbs
let's do this
double double toil and trouble
oh my god i know
oh my god it's like multiplicity i know
look
[Music]
look at this
you know i've always wanted a sibling
now you've got a twin
oh my god okay wait sit down yes oh my
god of course um so
i'm sort of getting a new idea
true do you think that we could both be
drew that's the best idea i have
ever heard think about all the prolific
work we could get done if there were two
of us
exactly
[Music]
guess who everyone
so we're going through the boards
and i just want to get
your opinions yes tom green is coming
back oh my god okay we love him
we love him okay yes i love that oh
out yeah yeah be right back oh of course
drew love you so much
welcome to hell everyone
nice drew's gone
bad drew's here
what did you just say to me
does anyone here have a good idea i am
drew barrymore god
starr i've never been kissed
watch your mouth
you're shopping online
you're on slack
mr great hair
does anyone here take their jobs
seriously
what did you just say to me
um just coordinating your schedule okay
can i get some damn tea
you all thought this was a game but true
gave me a lot of power
is this my tea
why did she drink this i don't know
oh we're not friends
god okay get to work and just do the
show
oh i'm sorry whose name is that yeah
that's what i thought
did i stutter
get to work
benny
oh
hey
drew are you being rude
now
yeah it's doing
our job drew i know but we have to be
really nice and respectful to everybody
okay so
the power got to me a little bit but
give me the wig
[Music]
okay
yeah it's me true
hey oh that was kind of kristen wiig
no
sorry
i'm looking for ideas this is so i'm
sorry your eyes are so blue it's
actually really pretty
oh
shut up
[Music]
you